اعلانات وتسريح بدات مطلع السنه وجاءت
اولا من شركه صغيره ومتوسطه ولكن موجه
التسريح الان طالت عمالقه التكنولوجيا مثل
متى وامازون واوبر
سوفت لدرجه انه تم تاسيس موقع الكتروني
ليف صوت اف واي يرصد كل الوظائف المفقوده
التي تجاوز عددها 150 الف وظيفه هذه السنه
ورغم ان لكل شركه اسبابها الخاصه الى ان
هناك عوامل مشتركه على القطاع اولا العديد
من تلك الشركات عينت الاف الموظفين خلال
جائع استجابه لطلب المتزايد على خدماتها
واملتا بان يدوم اسلوب المعيشه الرقميه
مات مثلا عينت اكثر من 15 الف موظفا في
اول تسعه شهور من السنه الجاريه ولكن قبل
اسابيع اعلن مرض مؤسس شركه انه سيسرح احد
عشر الف موظفا اي 13% من القوى العامله
امازون بدولها اعلنت الاستغناء عن عشره
الاف موظف في اكبر عمليه تسريح في تاريخها
على هذه الشركات ان تواجهها الواقع فهم
واجهوا عده فصول من تراجع الارادات والكل
يتساء ماذا ستفعل الشركه لتعامل مع الاداء
الصعب والتحديات والنتائج المخيبه ولكن
ايضا ماذا ستفعل استعدادا لسنه القادمه
التي ستكون صعبه والعديد من الشركات اخذت
خطوات للتسريح منها تويتر وامازون ومجتمع
المستثمرين يودوا ان تكون الشركات اكثر
انضبا وتشوفا
عامل الاخر وهو اجمل تكلفه المعيشه
وارتفاع معدل التضخم هذا بدوره ادى الى
تراجع الاعلانات عبر الانترنت والمنصات
الرقميه كما ان بعض تغيرات في قواعد
الخصوصيه لدى شركه مثل ابل ضربت سوق
الاعلانات وفي مجال التكنولوجيا الخدمه
الماليه طلقت الشركات ايضا ضربه من ارتفاع
اسعار الفائده
المستثمرون ايضا زاد من ضغوطهم على
الشركات لخفض تكاليفها
قامت العديد من هذه الشركات بالاستثمار
للنمو على المدى الطويل ولم تهتم بالربحيه
اعتقد ان هذه الاستراتيجيه انتهتماما ويجب
على الشركات اعاده ترتيب اولوياتها
والتركيز على المشروعات والمبادرات الاهم
فقط والعمل لنمو اعمالها وتحسين الاداء
الماليه لان المستثمرين لن يصبر 10 سنوات
كي يرون نتيجه الاستثمارات يجب ان يتخذوا
القرارات الصعبه
الى مصر الذي فصل النصف موظفي تويتر هو من
انصار ضروره خفض التكاليف في شركته
الجديده التي تواجه تحديات في زياده
ارباحها واضافه مستخدم جدد كما يرى البعض
ان رواتب ومزايا الموظفين في القطاع
التكنولوجي غير مستدامه واعلى من غيرها من
القطاعات ولكن ماذا عن اثر كل هذا على
المستثمرين في مجال التكنولوجيا الاجابه
تعتمد على حجم وطبيعه الشركه اذا كان
التسريح مجرد خطوه اخرى في طريقه انهيار
الشركه فمثل هذه الاخبار التي تعيد الثقل
المستثمرين ولكن اذا كان الهدف من التسريح
خفض التكاليف فهذا قد يكون مرحب به من قبل
المستثمرين لانه قلت يؤدي الى تحسن
الربحيه لندن